our eight news now investigators
tracking a stinky situation at a local
condo complex good evening to you I'm
Brian Loftus I'm Denise Valdez now this
is a building we first showed you more
than a year ago now the county is
offering leaders there to pay eight news
now investigator David Charles live near
Desert Inn in Paradise with how much
David
well Brian Denise there have been some
fixes to the outside of where we are
here but because the health district
says changes aren't happening quickly
enough particularly under us they've now
levied a ten thousand dollar fine
so many people have moved out it doesn't
back up like it used to Carl Osborne
isn't talking about the traffic outside
desert and Villas he's talking about the
pipes it's an issue the 80s now
investigators first showed you in 2021
when we visited then pieces of toilet
paper where raw sewage had come up
through the ground greeted us these
things should all be locked up the caps
for the sewer gas are still off dirts
dropping away from the foundation it
hasn't changed nothing has changed
nearly a year and a half later soapy
discharge right from the kitchen sink
pulled in the parking lot an inspection
report from nearly two years ago citing
backflow gray water walls buckling in
signs of structure failure the front of
the building is still shut
the ground is starting to cave in
Osborne's moved out since our first
visit though today he's taking care of a
friend's condo here the health district
ordering the HOA to fix the problems but
as recently as this July an inspector
found quote active sewage overflows and
unsecured sewage cleanouts you can walk
around this place
almost any time of day and smell raw
sewage from inside of people's homes in
2021 a spokesperson for the management
company and the HOA said they were
Expediting the process to fix the
problems here problems that have now
forced people like Osborne to move this
place is probably 50 vacant
now we did reach out to that
representative for the HOA and the
property management company again and we
did not hear back I also reached out to
the health district to see if that fine
has been paid and we are waiting on that
response we're live near Paradise in
Desert Inn tonight I'm David charns 8
news now David thank you in the health
district ordering the homeowners
association to fix that sewage issue
tenancy the HOA recently bumped its fees
to cover the cost of building wide
repairs